صلي انه
عط ما
كان عليكم
السلام ما كان واضح
وجه
[Silence]
جيب
كوكوي عمل
[Silence]
يعني
الله يجز
[Silence]
خيرج تعال
استغفر الله
س
[Silence]
‏som
السلام
[Silence]
الله
‏you get all the kids ins
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته ورحمه الله
وبركاته
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
لا
اله الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمد رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الفلا
الله
الله اكبر
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يدلله فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله صفي بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله
وادى الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الله تعالى
به غمه وجهد في الله حق جهاده حتى اتاه
اليقين اما
بعد فقال الله سبحانه وتعالى في القران
المجيد فرقان حميد بعد ق اعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ثم ا بعد ان اصدق
الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم وشرور محدثها وكل
محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في
النار رب اشرح لي صدر ويسر لي امري واحلل
عقده من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم لا سحل الا
ما جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحزن اذا شئت
سحلا ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي
العظيم الله ربنا وفقت نا ومان فنعم
ونص
الله
pra and
[Silence]
الله
سال محم صلى الله عليه
ومال
dark allowing
‏mercy he and cho from what hees there
is
noting jud and
not made
days for
[Silence]
ضان ضان
‏year
1445 as
[Silence]
‏days حث رول الله صلى الله عليهم
عن انس ابن مالك قال قال رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم لا تقوم ساعه حتى يتقارب
الزمان فتكون السنه كشهر والشهر كجمعه
وتكون الجمعه كاليوم واليوم
كعه انسن
مال صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏that year mon mon
a palm le trees
anding arec
مما
حديث
امام eyes
[Silence]
65 years they done voles upon
of 24
‏wake again and same
ham same over again time
and so
things
as we could not the would not pass the
day of frid the frid would not arve
‏fr fr
fr you would go and may have a go to
your friend
house was
[Silence]
‏the not
fock الله سانى
[Silence]
‏because
mindful
howes الله
سبهالى حث صل
[Silence]
علال
andit
alls bl مح
فقال عليه الصلاه والسلام حديث
صحيح
ملم رجب رضي الله عنه افضل الصيام بعد
رمضان شهر الله المحرم واف الصلاه بعد
الفرض الصلاه صلاه كما قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى ان عده شهور عند الله
اث الله
سبهالى ح ذلك ديني ف
[Silence]
انج رسول الله صل الله عليه
وسلم حديث
اضليا بعد رمضان شهر الله
محرم شحر الله المحم
محم الله سبحانه
وتالى
اللهانه وتالى
اللهه
اللهانه لله
الجع حث
محرم
الله الله واض صلاه بعد الصلاه صلاه
[Silence]
‏and
andas right you work all 12 hour you and
bless exage
[Silence]
حث ابعيد الخدر ضي الله
عنهي يعني
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى الا بعد الله
بذلك يوم وجه ال اللهانه
‏the hell
fire with
me
years one one
‏am
am الله سانه
وتالى
حثمه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله
يا رسول الله مرني بامر
ينفعني ينفعني الله ب قال عليك بالصيام
فانه لا مثل
له الله سبحانه
وتالى رول
الحمدله
very
bl we have
cars we have gas in
‏wees
i
life from air
‏sister h
currently
about was 300000
people
and prob
[Silence]
اللهى people
‏as soon as all the need to turned the
po up we hot so i walked by gently and i
said you know hell is hotter soing i
know it's
okay now if you know me personally you i
say this things out loud all the time so
you know i do please do excuse me i
don't mean anything ill by it i just
just say it because this is something i
to
do we have toe that the struggle for
this isor
‏wor wor
let
there in the parad forever and there
isli difficult there
there the
‏the struggles have are tempor this
world is
temporary so i encourage you and
myself to take the
opportun الله
سال
الله الله
سال easy
الله
[Silence]
سقول قول هذا استغفر الله لكم وساء
المسلمين فيستغفرون
انغ
[Silence]
الرح الحمد لله الحمد للهد احد الفرد الذ
ل يلد ولم يولد ول يك لهف
احد for
[Silence]
صلى
‏say me
inic
there mystic magic the word
so the
that نح عليه واللام
الله سبحانه
وتالى بي
اسرا
عليه
and رسول اللهصلى الله عليه وسلم اه
المكه
رول صل علسلم
نبح ابم
عليه ضان
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى موى عليهه
[Silence]
عل
‏that i next
year
as from
اه
اسرايل
محم
حث رول الله صلم
[Silence]
‏as الله
سالى ‏we follow on the
tuor m and tu that signi fur more up to
times i encourage my and you to be
mindful of this
mon
and
att
moneh a
cr we have mon and days
‏and i
anger
all الله
سانتال اللهرم
[Silence]
مح days
د
ع الله سبحانه
وتالى اللهانه
وتالى اللهبه وتال
م
[Silence]
عليه at that there was only one
today
fiv all
ev
asky fter
[Silence]
صل
عليه اله الله محد رول
الله الله
[Silence]
‏sister
‏he
[Silence]
الله يه
صلوا على النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا
عليه وسلموا تسليما عباد الله ان الله
يامركم بالعدل والاحسان واتا القرب منغي
يعزكم لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا الله العظيم
ذكركم واشكر وازد لكم وذكر الله اكبر
وقوموا الى صم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على الصلاه حي
على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
[Silence]
وعت
اللهانه الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم راط الذين انعمت عليه
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والتين
والزيتون وطور سينين
وهذا البلد
الامين لقد خلقنا
الانسان في احسن
تقويم ثم رددناه اسفل
سافلين الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فلهم اجر غير
ممون فما يكذبك بعد بالدين
اليس الله باحكم
الحاكمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بس الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله اذا
جاء نصر الله والفتح
ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفر
انه كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر لا
اله الله
اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله
الا
الله
اكبر
اشهد اللهم
[Silence]
السلام عليكم رحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام
[Silence]
عل
‏come
pleas guin paring in
house
any
any resp for that mindful
‏seair sister are downstairs you come
[Silence]
thees الله
‏that's
[Silence]
اوك جزاك الله او اوكي
‏thank you thank you beautiful
[Silence]
‏in
الح
[Silence]
‏my ‏s
‏ja
[Silence]
‏den
‏j
[Silence]
‏a
‏s
[Silence]
‏inte ‏e
‏l
[Silence]
‏r ‏a
ا
[Silence]
عندك اهل
بالسودان ان شاء الله في ح
دا على الكراسي لا دائ على السودان ولا
دائ على
[Silence]
‏non
‏bra
[Silence]
تش
جلاس ما تحطي ايدك على الازاز
[Silence]
‏c
عل
[Silence]
السلام عليكم
شاء
[Silence]
وال
‏qu
[Silence]
‏inte
عل ‏let
[Silence]
‏h
ب
[Silence]
‏den
اكب
م
[Silence]
‏way
‏f
[Silence]
‏mal
‏c